let's go to austin in sumner illinois
austin what's going on brother
um not too much i've just got a few
questions for you guys
bring him on brother how can we help
okay well um i'm 13
and i start i'm starting my own
i'm starting a little business it's
called akw farms
um i'm i'm going to be selling goat
smoke this summer
be it um honey i right now i make shows
and stuff i do a lot of woods
wood crafts and stuff and i was just
wondering
how much money i need to be putting back
into the business
and when i can start taking money out
for me austin
you just made my whole day brother you
are awesome
awesome also how long how long have you
uh been uh
talking about this and doing it
um i've been talking about it for about
two to three years i actually
started it you could say i started about
two years ago
when i got goats but i really started
selling stuff
last year at the farmer's market i make
shells out of pallet boards
wow okay all right that's so cool austin
well here's the thing man
uh what i'm going to do is because
there's so much we can we can walk
through this
austin um and i just love your heart
behind it so what i'm going to do is uh
when we get off the phone with you
i'm going to have kelly send you have
your mom or dad say
stand by so they can give you uh so they
can give kelly your address because i'm
going to send you a copy of my toolbox
kit
my teen entrepreneurial toolbox kit
uh where i'm going to literally walk you
through the whole process so when you
get this kit young man
i want you to um read it
read it with your parents and it's going
to teach you your sales pitch it's going
to teach you how to make a
business budget and i'm going to even
teach you exactly how should you be
allocating your funds
the first thing is going gonna really
figure out you know okay what does it
cost you to run the business
okay uh you gotta buy materials you
gotta buy products
so you gotta put money back into the
business so we need to identify
how much do you need to put back in
there and then from there then yes what
are you going to be paying
yourself what are you going to be
putting into your checking account into
your savings account
uh but i think right now the main thing
is
that you will need to sit down with your
parents and figure out
how much money do i need every month
to keep producing what you're producing
have you all even talked about that
already
um well
kind of yeah i've got luckily for me i
can get um pallets for free my dad
worked for ups
and whenever they're done with the
loading
he can just pick up pallets and we have
a bunch of stockpiles
so you've got a raw materials material
just sitting there that's fantastic yeah
what what other um tools do you need
real quick um
austin um uh i've got a pallet buster
which my dad was one of them too before
so
okay he it's his but i can use it um
i mean i use a circular saw a jigsaw
hammer nails and usually some hooks
okay so it sounds like it sounds like
your parents are already setting you up
to win
so the income that you would need to put
back into the company and then the
income you would use to pay yourself
may be a little different uh depending
upon it sounds like your father can get
you the tools and the material for free
so you may be looking at 90 80 of your
um
your income that you make will go into
you into your future
and maybe 10 or 20 would go back to your
father for helping him get the materials
or
helping your father get some materials
uh for you down the road so
i'm loving it young man let me ask you
this question that's off subject
and again i want you to stay on the line
and kelly's going to get your address uh
to send you a copy of my teen
entrepreneur toolbox kit but what are
you going to do with all this money
like when you start making this money
how are you going to spend it
well um there's a few things is
i'm like i said i i'm buying the cash in
with some of my money i already have
saved up from
because i do 4-h and stuff like that so
i have money saved up from the options
so i'm gonna be buying part of a cow me
and my parents are gonna go in on it all
together that's what i'm talking about
austin
and one of the big things i'm wanting is
i'm saving up for a 22 mag
rifle and a
this dude is what's up this man just
said i'm saving for a gun and a
four-wheeler that sounds like a bright
kid
uh to me no it was a cow and a 22 in a
four-wheeler
you are my hero austin
this is unique this is interesting hey
man i'm rooting for you i am celebrating
you austin
uh stay on the line man kelly will get
your address she'll send you that teen
entrepreneur toolbox kid
uh when you get the cow when you get the
rifle when you get the four-wheeler man
send me and john a picture of that
uh so we can celebrate with you man if
you guys would like to see it
before i um well not before but when i
before i get to send you guys pictures
you can subscribe to my youtube channel
it's akw
farms oh hey listen to this number one
brother knows how to push his name and
hey you are better than i am at that so
well done
and yes we will check out your website
tell us one more time
akw farms my initials akw
farms good folks go to that website get
yourself some honey and some goat milk
from a 13 year old entrepreneur who's
put it together and all he wants america
is a cow and a 22 and a four-wheeler
hey help him out i am not mad at him at
all man that's hey he could have said
xbox and what good for that kid that
makes man he just made everything better